let me tell you though that i was not
okay um watching this um it it might
literally be my worst nightmare like i'm
not a i'm not a good flyer i'm an
anxious flyer oh no
so from that to like the stress of you
surviving in the wilderness um
you know how do how would you how would
you fare doing that
i always like to say that i would
survive
because i'm a very you know
i'm like very gung-ho and like a
go-getter and all that kind of stuff but
probably i would die
very probably because i would probably
do something really stupid like climb a
tree to see if i could see anything and
then like fall and die
or i would like eat something that
is not good to eat
and
i just i'm not an outdoorsy person at
all so i feel like it wouldn't be
it wouldn't be good for me
um by myself especially
but uh but i've learned a lot about by
making the show i learned a lot and i
think i would last a little longer now
with the knowledge that i have because
of this show
absolutely absolutely um now you say
you're not outdoorsy um but your
character does a lot of swimming um and
speaking to other people who shot in
canada
um what was that like
honestly it was
it was the most terrifying thing but
also the most fun
weird it was like a weird feeling
because i think one of my biggest fears
is drowning and so doing all these
underwater scenes
uh especially the ones inside the plane
were terrifying because it was dark it
was small can't see anything
um
and i was a little scared
but then i also like had the most fun we
were in the lake you know like i was
swimming and and we
we also shot at a tank for a week this
gigantic
tank that was like 20 feet deep and like
i don't know how wide and the plane was
in there and it was just
my first time doing a lot of this so i
was enjoying it i was having so much fun
when i wasn't terrified i was just
laughing and having a ball that's
amazing that's such a good way to look
at it as far as like um
not being scared to do it even though
it's something that you might have
scared of
now i know that you guys filmed in
british columbia which is beautiful
um
yes so what was your favorite part about
working in working there on on location
i think my favorite part was
all of what we shot in whistler and
squamish which is all the outdoors stuff
it was so beautiful to just be able to
be outdoors all day breathing fresh air
in the sun
um
you know eating like we would eat lunch
and we would just sit by the lake and
like it just felt like summer camp
in a way it was you know grueling
because it was long hours and you know
getting to the location sometimes was a
trek and all of that but
but it was a beautiful
rest and a beautiful respite from you
know being indoors for two years you
know in the pandemic so it was
it felt like a gift really to be able to
do that
that's amazing
um
now speaking of it sort of being like a
truck and a bit of an adventure i went
through your instagram and i noticed
that you
referenced this project as
um a crazy adventure
um
how would keep breathing rank among your
other
uh series or films that you've done
uh in what way
like in in like the craziest
yeah
it's definitely it's definitely
top of the list and yeah it's the the
hardest the hardest thing i've ever done
is definitely this show
not just because of like all the crazy
things that i had to do but also because
i was i was by myself most of the time
and so that meant
you know
a lot of forced calls not sleeping
enough had to like get back up the next
day and be again by myself in front of
the camera and so it was exhausting
but i knew that it was going to be
exhausting when i signed on for it and
that's and that's probably because i'm a
masochist what what attracted me about
the project
um
and i'm so grateful for the experience
because i also got to be you know close
with the crew which was a new experience
because it was them and me
all day every day and so i it felt like
it was our show you know like it was it
was very much ours and i think
it's the the first time that i feel like
the crew
is really invested in the story like
obviously like you know i work on movies
and all that and the crew always loves
and is excited about what we're doing
but this time it felt different because
i think they were very aware that
they were a huge part of it because it
was me by myself and everything that
they were doing around me was
you know elevating me and making it and
and
it was just a a beautiful and very
different experience for me and i and
and it changed me definitely
made me force me to grow in a lot of
ways as a person and as an artist
that's amazing that's it's so wonderful
that you've had to have an experience
like that
now you're ready to do like survivor man
or in the wild i'm so ready i'm so ready
for anything i feel like if i did this
show i can do anything so i
and i also got to do you know a lot of
stunts and a lot of wire work and water
work and like all of that stuff for the
first time and i and i got a little bit
addicted and so now i'm like what's next
i i need to do more of that
that's amazing well we're looking
forward to it whatever it is that you do
next um we're looking forward to
everyone seeing this
and thanks so much for your time
thank you so much kate
have a good one